Speaker 1: You know, I really was feeling
like we had kind of seen it all recently
related to strange comparisons to the Holocaust or
references to Jews or thinly veiled anti-Semitism.
You know, we heard about Marjorie Taylor
Green's so-called Jewish space. Lazar's
Marjorie Taylor Green saying wearing a mask
on the House floor is like the Holocaust or
mandatory vaccinations which don't exist are
like the Holocaust. But a woman claiming to
be a registered nurse, she may be a registered
nurse. I just mean, I don't know that to be true.
She says she's a registered nurse. It's scary if
a registered nurse would believe what I'm about
to play for you. But a woman claiming to be a
registered nurse appeared on CNN yesterday and
claimed specifically that covid vaccination and
the medical trial process for developing new drugs
is like Nazi medical experiments of the World
War Two era. She says it's not exactly like it,
but it's sort of like it. You simply have to
see this to believe it. This is a completely
disgusting woman. Let's get right into it.
Speaker 3: We're not going to say this is
nearly as big as the Holocaust was, but
Speaker 1: it's not nearly as big as
the Holocaust was. But and then here we go
Speaker 3: at the beginning, the way they
did make people have trials and injections,
medications, procedures against their will.
This is pretty much what they're doing right now.
Speaker 1: What who's having procedures
against their will? Who's taking medications
against their will? Who's being forced to do
anything? Do you remember what was what
will get to Nazi medical experiments
Speaker 3: they're having forcing people
to take a shot when they don't want to.
Speaker 1: And nobody is being forced to take
a shot. Nobody is being forced to take a shot.
If you want to travel to some countries, you can
decide I will do the things that are required to
go to that country. If you want to sit in the
vaccinated section, that will be full rather
than only one third full at certain stadiums, then
you can choose to go and get yourself vaccinated.
Nobody is being forced to take a shot.
Speaker 3: They're not giving the proper
informed consent like nobody is being told the
risk factors before getting this injection.
Speaker 1: That is completely untrue. When I went
and I got my very, very powerful Moderna vaccine,
I was screened with like an eight question
initial screening. I was then given like
a two page document about it. Then the person
giving me the shot asked me a bunch of questions.
Then I was told to stay in observation for
fifteen minutes and for my second shot,
all of the same stuff happened. All of it is
nothing this woman is saying is true. It's hard.
It's actually hard to keep up with all
the things she's saying that aren't true.
Speaker 3: I just want to be clear, though. I
mean, you do realize that there is no comparison
here to the Holocaust, right? I mean, the Nazi
doctor held medical experiments on people and some
died. Some I mean, it was painful. It was awful.
Speaker 1: How could you. Yeah, but somebody's
arm hurt from the vaccine then.
Speaker 3: Compare it to that.
I didn't compare to the Holocaust, but I
did compare it to the beginnings of it,
which is the Nuremberg trials.
Speaker 1:
Oh, that is it's not it's it was
like the beginning of the Holocaust.
The Nuremberg trials, the Nuremberg
trials were at the end. They took p